riots in France for the fourth night
running
from Marseille in the South to Leon
grenope and the capital of Paris public
property cars
and businesses looted towards and
destroyed the Nationwide anger on the
streets follows the killing of 17 year
old Niall during a police traffic stop
on Tuesday
the president of France is calling for
calm and says the situation has been
hijacked to spread Anarchy
this is an unacceptable exploitation of
the death of a teenager which we deplore
this time should all be about
contemplation and respect I strongly
condemn those who are using this
situation to try and create disorder and
Target our institutions that sentiment
echoed by Francis football team captain
Killian and Bape tweeting a statement
from the players appealing for calm
saying they all understand the anger but
dialogue needs to be the focus not
violence
following hundreds of arrests already
this week
hundreds more were detained overnight
the mayor of Marseille says leading and
violence is unacceptable and urged the
government in Paris to send police
reinforcements
private funeral for Niall is due to be
held on Saturday as France remains a
nation in turmoil
Imran lahan Al Jazeera
and live now to our